and we thought we'd seen you play
everything but
first witch mostly [ __ ]
my first witch but i hear you went
through a phase
you got offered a lot of witches when i
was 40 when i turned 40
i was offered three which is in one year
and it was sending me a signal i felt
about hollywood and how they felt about
people turning 40.
so i felt uh bad and i and it made me
sort of
i had a like a little my backup you know
and so
no i didn't want to play them so a lot's
changed in the last five years for you
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so smooth
it never works like that hello
hello hi what's your name uh james james
lovely james
and what do you do uh i'm a civil
servant a civil servant lovely in london
here uh yes in london
are you from the london area uh no i
live in london but i'm originally from
um
suffolk oh oh yeah it's a suffolk
massive
yeah is he mentioned in the song
probably yeah what school did you go to
um
so i went to brandeston oh sweet yeah
i went to primary school yeah oh okay
did we know each other
[Applause]
glasses what do you yeah james hello
yeah james yes
me that's the one what the [ __ ]
dude he was my best fate growing up
and now you're talking to him on a
monastery i'm not having my specs and
he's like
oh my god can we not flip him and just
get him out of here
do you have a story or do you well yeah
i did but please let it be about edge
is about it okay okay tell your story
then we'll flip you and then
i'll sit with you okay okay cool so um
yeah this is so random mate yeah
it's really weird um yeah when we were
younger ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates
and i remember one time um one time he
was coming around for tea
um and i forgot to tell mum he was a
vegetarian
um at that point anyway and um so mum
cooked
i think the sausage and mash for tea um
and ed said you know after the meal
these are the best sausages i've ever
tasted you know where did you get them
from
a mum had to lie because she had no clue
um
and so yeah 16 years later i'm really
sorry
first time i ever had me and also the
first time i ever watched the simpsons
episode was around your house
now a lot of people don't know this but
uh eddie is in fact
a highly trained master magician now you
remember the magic circle
um no
[Applause]
wow that moment was one of like deep
despair and lost
that was a dream when i was a child
never happened yeah
please tell me you're about to you're
about to your no because i know that i
know that you can do amazing magic
because we have here just a totally
ordinary coloring book
oh this is totally ordinary oh
but eddie can do magic with it
isn't that right eddie i mean
are you sitting comfortably children
[Applause]
so i loved paul daniels you probably
weren't who will tell you as well the
late paul daniels was an amazing
magician that used to
be on telly every saturday night i was
obsessed with him and
i this is my moment to be on television
doing magic when are you ready i'm ready
i'm ready
this is a coloring book there is nothing
weird or
bizarre about it other than it says the
word magic on the front of it
uh there is actually nothing in the
coloring book i'm showing you you see
there is
nothing i can see there's nothing in it
but ryan yes
will you blow on the coloring book
i thank you fun
no harder than that
[Applause]
let's see what that's done shall we
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay so the next stage is so we've got
now we have pictures
ben we have pictures we have pictures i
can see the questions will you
blow on it give me your full smog
okay good one was it
[Laughter]
i'm a wizard
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like wizarding crossover the potential
of
doctor strange will you give us a spell
ben as a cajon yeah
vegas actually better than
drum roll uh
[Applause]
you are a proper nerd aren't you uh i
mean when it comes to harry potter i'm a
massive massive nerd
we know that because you posted this
book is this your 12th or you're about
12 or 13 here
this is margot robbie look how uncool
do you know what's particularly pathetic
about this picture a couple things
really
um number one i'll let you point them
out
number one it's my birthday that's how i
chose to spend my birthday
what was in the cup uh number two i'm
drinking tea
number three i'm wearing glasses even
though i don't need glasses i lied to
the optometrist because i wanted to have
glasses like that
now daniel i think you were were you a
harry potter fan
i love harry potter i just to get round
to reading the last one okay so
i just i
are you kidding me so you've read one to
six and you haven't read the seven yeah
i don't know are you actually kidding
good and bear for twins i'm not going to
be able to sleep tonight
worrying about you life is a game you
mean so
i just like you it's just you keep it on
the edge i mean this is insane to me
do you know another fun fact my husband
is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
tell us so i'll stop hijacking the show
after this
because i'm not here to publicize harry
potter
my husband is in the harry potter movies
i know
i was like had you told me sooner we
would have been married very quickly but
he was
um an extra he was like when he was a
little kid he's like one of the slother
extras you know when draco like pushes
some kids out of the way to
to see buckbeak in the third book yeah
he pushes my husband out of the way
oh yeah
were you ever an extra in harry potter
no no someone i
had a my friend was an extra at school
then i asked him like how did you get
into acting and he didn't tell me
because you i posted a picture of
yourself so you posted a picture of
yourself as i don't know how old you are
you're
a little boy here and uh you look like
you could be
in hogwarts here you are good
you showed me that when we were filming
i love that i feel better about my photo
now
yeah i know people you went to school
with must be so surprised
you could you could um kind of fill in
as your host as quiz master because
we've got some questions we've got some
questions
this is a this is uh this is like a
friend's
trivia oh oh oh she's gonna win oh i
don't know that
friends no well really i think you you
there's some free there's some of you
all know if they don't know that i'm
sure the audience will know okay now do
you hear the questions
okay okay julie no cheating
uh well yeah christy you're you're all
competing yeah yeah i know the answer so
i can't
uh i'd like you to put your hand up if
you know the answer yes sir
no no no is that fair enough yes are you
ready
yes sort of yes question what is rachel
wearing
in her first ever scene oh
oh richard oh i can't answer that yes
you can a wedding
a wedding dress is the correct answer
[Applause]
all right next question what is the next
line
after this is about you being a brat
wanting what you can't
have reese can't have the only thing i
can't have
is dairy correct
[Applause]
because i said it on this one
[Applause]
chris how did rachel ruin the british
trifle
oh oh ow
i put i i i the uh i put beef in it
beef at the bottom i layered beef into
the trifle
well you didn't you didn't sh you put
shepherd's pie oh right
and the separate spa is not made with
beef it's made with lamb sheep
wow he's firm but fair
you'd expect a landlord to know that yes
yes
[Laughter]
what song does rachel sing to get her
daughter to stop
crying baby
baby got back is the correct answer
that's one for the audience and for a
bonus point
jennifer would you like to sing the
opening line of the song
uh i like big butts and i cannot lie
there's an extra point
i know yeah i thought you meant the
opening
line of the theme song oh cause i could
have told you that
do you want to sing about it so no one
told you that it's gonna
be this way
yes and this is for for you for me
oh no the question is when ross dated
rachel why did he feel it was fine to
sleep
with other women and
i know it's because he said we were on a
break
[Applause]
very good
you